J'aimerais commencer par une observation,
qui est que si j'ai appris quoi que ce soit au cours de l'année passée,
c'est que l'ironie suprême
de publier un livre sur la lenteur
est que vous devez aller le promouvoir partout, vraiment vite.
J'ai l'impression de passer la plupart de mon temps en ce moment, vous savez,
à filer à toute allure de ville en ville, de studio en studio,
d'interview en interview,
en offrant le livre en minuscules petits bouts.
Car tout le monde ces jours-ci
veut savoir comment ralentir,
mais ils veulent savoir comment ralentir vraiment vite. Donc...
donc j'ai fait un spot sur CNN l'autre jour
où j'ai en fait passé plus de temps au maquillage qu'à parler à l'antenne.
Et je pense que -- ce n'est pas vraiment surprenant, n'est-ce pas?
Car c'est le genre de monde dans lequel nous -- vivons maintenant,
un monde bloqué sur avance rapide.
Un monde obsédé par la vitesse,
à tout faire plus vite, et à bourrer de plus en plus de choses
dans moins en moins de temps.
Chaque moment de la journée ressemble à
une course contre la montre.
Pour emprunter une phrase à Carrie Fisher, qui est --
c'est dans ma bio là, mais je vais la sortir de nouveau --
"De nos jours même une gratification instantanée prend trop de temps."
Et
si vous pensez à la façon dont on essaie d'améliorer les choses, qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
Non, on les accélère, n'est-ce pas ? On avait l'habitude de composer un numéro; maintenant on a la numérotation abrégée.
On avait l'habitude de lire; maintenant on lit en diagonale. On avait l'habitude de marcher; maintenant on fait de la marche rapide.
Et bien sûr, on avait l'habitude de draguer et maintenant on fait du speed dating.
Et même les choses qui sont par nature lentes --
on essaie de les accélérer. Alors --
Alors j'étais à New York récemment, et je suis passé à côté d'une salle de gym
qui avait une publicité sur la fenêtre pour un nouveau cours, un nouveau cours du soir.
Et c'était pour, vous l'avez deviné, du yoga rapide.
Donc cette -- la solution parfaite pour les professionnels en manque de temps
qui veulent, vous savez, faire la salutation au soleil,
mais qui ne veulent prendre que 20 minutes pour ça.
Je veux dire, voilà un peu des exemples extrêmes
et ils sont amusants et bons à faire rire.
Mais il y a un point très sérieux,
et je pense que dans la précipitation de la vie courante,
on perd souvent de vue le dommage
que nous cause cette forme de vie à la "bipbip le coyote".
Nous marinons tellement dans la culture de la rapidité
que nous remarquons à peine la taxe qu'elle nous fait payer
sur chaque aspect de nos vies.
Sur notre santé, notre alimentation, notre travail,
nos relations, l'environnement et notre communauté.
Et parfois il faut une --
alarme de réveil, n'est-ce pas, pour --
nous alerter sur le fait que nous sommes en train de nous précipiter dans nos vies,
à la place de les vivre vraiment; que nous sommes en train
de vivre la vie rapide, au lieu de la bonne vie.
Et je pense que pour beaucoup de gens, cette alarme
prend la forme d'une maladie.
Vous savez, un burn-out, ou quand le corps finit par dire,
"Je n'en peux plus," et jette l'éponge.
Ou peut être une relation part en fumée
car nous n'avons pas eu le temps, ou la patience,
ou la tranquillité,
d'être avec l'autre personne, de l'écouter.
Et mon alarme est arrivée quand j'ai commencé
à lire des histoires pour endormir mon fils,
et j'ai découvert qu'à la fin de la journée,
j'allais dans sa chambre et je ne pouvais pas ralentir -- vous savez,
je lisais à toute vitesse "Le chat dans le chapeau."
j'étais -- vous savez, je sautais des lignes ici,
des paragraphes là, parfois une page entière
et bien sûr, mon petit garçon connaissait l'histoire par coeur, alors on se disputait.
Et ce qui aurait dû être le plus relaxant, le plus intime,
le plus tendre moment de la journée,
quand un père s'assied pour lire une histoire à son fils,
est devenu plutôt cette espèce de bataille de volontés entre gladiateurs;
un affrontement entre sa rapidité et mon --
plutôt, ma rapidité et sa lenteur.
Et ça a continué pendant un certain temps,
jusqu'à ce que je me surprenne moi-même à lire un article
avec des astuces pour économiser du temps, pour les gens rapides.
Et l'un d'eux faisait référence à une série de livres appelés
"L'histoire du soir en 1 minute."
Et je -- je grimace en disant ces mots maintenant,
mais ma première réaction à l'époque a été très différente.
Mon premier réflexe a été de dire,
"Hallelujah -- quelle brillante idée!
C'est exactement ce que je cherche pour accélérer encore plus l'histoire du soir."
Mais heureusement,
une lumière s'est allumée au-dessus de ma tête, et ma réaction d'après a été très différente,
et j'ai pris du recul, et j'ai pensé,
"Whoa -- vous savez, est-ce qu'on en est vraiment arrivé à ce point?
Suis-je tellement pressé que je suis disposé
à me débarrasser de mon fils avec un octet de son à la fin de la journée?"
Et j'ai -- j'ai mis de côté le journal --
et j'allais embarquer dans un avion -- et je suis resté assis là,
et j'ai fait quelque chose que je n'avais pas fait depuis longtemps -- qui était de ne rien faire.
J'ai juste pensé, et j'ai pensé longtemps et fort.
Et au moment où je suis descendu de l'avion, j'ai décidé que je voulais faire quelque chose à ce sujet.
Je voulais enquêter sur toute cette culture de la vitesse,
et ce que c'était en train de me faire à moi et à tout le monde. Et je --
Et j'avais deux questions dans la tête.
La première était, comment sommes-nous devenus aussi rapides ?
Et la deuxième était, est-il possible,
ou même souhaitable, de ralentir?
Maintenant, si vous pensez à
la façon dont notre monde est devenu aussi accéléré, les suspects ordinaires vous viennent à l'esprit.
Vous pensez à, vous savez, l'urbanisation,
la consommation, la place du travail, la technologie.
Mais je pense que si vous passez au-delà
de ces forces vous arrivez à ce qui pourrait être le levier
plus profond, le fond de la question,
qui est la façon dont nous pensons le temps lui-même.
Dans d'autres cultures, le temps est cyclique.
Il est vu comme bougeant en grands
cercles sans précipitation.
Il est constamment en train de se renouveler et de se rafraîchir.
Tandis qu'à l'Ouest, le temps est linéaire.
C'est une ressource finie,
il s'écoule en permanence.
Ou vous l'utilisez, ou vous le perdez.
Le temps c'est de l'argent, comme l'a dit Benjamin Franklin.
Et je pense que ce que -- ce que ça nous fait psychologiquement
c'est que -- ça crée une équation.
Le temps est rare, donc que faisons-nous ?
Eh bien -- eh bien, nous accélérons, n'est-ce pas ?
Nous essayons de faire de plus et plus de choses avec de moins en moins de temps.
Nous transformons chaque moment de chaque journée
en une course jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée.
Une ligne d'arrivée, d'ailleurs, que nous n'atteignons jamais,
mais une ligne d'arrivée quand même.
Et je pense que la question est,
est-il possible de se libérer de cette façon de penser?
Et heureusement, la réponse est oui, car
ce que j'ai découvert, quand j'ai commencé à regarder autour de moi, c'est qu'il y a --
une réaction violente, globale, contre cette culture qui
nous dit que plus vite est toujours mieux, et qu'être plus occupé c'est le mieux.
Partout dans le monde, les gens sont en train de faire l'impensable:
ils sont en train de ralentir, et de découvrir que
bien que la sagesse conventionnelle nous dise que si vous ralentissez, vous êtes tué sur la route,
le contraire finalement est vrai.
Qu'en ralentissant aux bons moments,
les gens découvrent qu'ils font tout mieux.
Ils mangent mieux, ils font mieux l'amour, ils font mieux du sport,
ils travaillent mieux, ils vivent mieux.
Et dans ce genre de chaudron
de moments, d'endroits, et d'actes de décélération,
repose ce à quoi beaucoup de gens font maintenant référence en parlant du
Mouvement Lent International.
Maintenant si vous me permettez un petit acte d'hypocrisie,
je vais juste vous donner un rapide aperçu de ce qui --
ce qui est en train de se passer dans le Mouvement Lent. Si vous pensez à la nourriture,
plusieurs d'entre vous aurons entendu parler du mouvement "Slow Food".
Démarré en Italie, mais qui s’est propagé à travers le monde,
et qui a maintenant 100 000 membres
dans 50 pays.
Et il est mû un message très simple et intelligent,
qui est qu'on obtient plus de plaisir et plus de santé
de notre nourriture quand on
la cultive, la cuisine et la consomme à une vitesse raisonnable.
Je pense aussi que l'explosion du
mouvement des fermes bio, et la renaissance des marchés fermiers,
est une autre -- sont d'autres illustrations
du fait que les gens veulent désespérément échapper à cette façon de
manger, cuisiner et cultiver leur nourriture
selon un emploi du temps industriel.
Ils veulent revenir à des rythmes plus lents.
Et du Mouvement "Slow Food" est sorti quelque chose
qu'on appelle le mouvement des Villes Lentes, qui a débuté en Italie,
mais s'est propagé à travers l'Europe et au-delà.
Et dans ce mouvement, les villes
commencent à repenser leur manière d'organiser le paysage urbain,
pour que les gens soient encouragés à -- ralentir
et respirer les roses et se connecter les uns avec les autres.
Alors ils peuvent restreindre le trafic,
ou mettre un banc dans un parc ou quelques espaces verts.
Et d'une certaine manière, ces changements apportent plus que la somme de leurs parties,
car je pense que quand une Ville Lente devient officiellement une Ville Lente,
c'est comme une sorte de déclaration philosophique.
C'est dire au reste du monde, et aux habitants de cette ville,
que nous croyons qu’au 21e siècle,
la lenteur a un rôle à jouer.
En médecine, je pense que beaucoup de gens sont profondément désabusés
par la mentalité de la réparation rapide
que vous trouvez dans la médecine traditionnelle.
Et des millions d'entre eux à travers le monde sont en train de se tourner vers
des formes de médecines complémentaires et alternatives,
qui tendent à s'appuyer sur un genre de
guérison plus lente, plus douce, plus holistique.
Maintenant, évidemment le jury délibère toujours sur plusieurs de ces thérapies complémentaires,
et je doute personnellement que le lavement au café
gagne un jour, disons, l'approbation générale.
Mais d'autres traitements
comme l'acuponcture et les massages, et même la simple relaxation,
ont clairement une forme de bénéfice.
Et partout, les écoles de médecines de premier ordre commencent --
commencent à étudier ces choses pour découvrir comment elles fonctionnent,
et ce que nous pourrions en apprendre.
Le sexe. Il y a vraiment du sexe rapide partout, non ?
J'étais en train d'arriver à --
bon -- pas de jeu de mots ici.
J'étais en train de faire mon chemin, disons, lentement vers Oxford,
et je suis passé chez un vendeur de journaux, et j'ai vu un magazine,
un magazine masculin, et ça disait en première page,
"Comment amener votre partenaire à l'orgasme en 30 secondes."
Donc, vous savez, même le sexe
est chronométré actuellement.
Maintenant, vous savez,
j'aime un coup vite-fait autant que mon voisin,
mais je pense qu'il y a terriblement à gagner
avec le sexe lent -- à ralentir dans la chambre à coucher.
Vous savez, vous accédez à -- ces plus profonds,
genre de courants, vous savez, des courants psychologiques, émotionnels, spirituels,
et vous obtenez un meilleur orgasme de cette accumulation.
Vous pouvez en avoir plus pour votre argent, disons.
Je veux dire, les Pointer Sisters l'ont dit avec plus d’éloquence, n'est-ce pas
quand elles ont chanté les prouesses d'un amant avec une main lente.
Maintenant, nous nous sommes tous moqués de Sting
il y a quelques années quand il s’est converti au tantrisme,
mais avancez rapidement de quelques années, et vous trouvez maintenant des couples de tous les âges
qui affluent aux ateliers, ou qui, peut-être juste
tout seuls dans leurs chambres à coucher, trouvent des moyens
de ralentir et de vivre une meilleure sexualité.
Bien sûr, en Italie où -- je veux dire, les Italiens ont toujours l'air de savoir
où trouver leur plaisir --
ils ont lancé un mouvement officiel pour le Sexe Lent.
La place du travail --
dans la majeure partie du monde --
l'Amérique du Nord étant une exception notable --
les heures de travail ont diminué.
Et l'Europe est un exemple de ça,
et les gens trouvent que leur qualité de vie augmente
quand ils travaillent moins, et aussi
que leur productivité horaire augmente.
Maintenant, il y clairement des problèmes avec
la semaine de 35h en France --
trop, trop vite, trop rigide.
Mais d'autres pays en Europe, notamment les pays nordiques,
ont montré que c'était possible
d'avoir une économie du tonnerre
sans être un drogué du travail.
Et la Norvège, la Suède,
le Danemark et la Finlande se classent maintenant
parmi les 6 nations les plus compétitives du monde,
et ils travaillent le genre d'heures qui rendrait un Américain moyen
vert de jalousie.
Et si vous allez plus loin qu'au niveau d'un pays,
en descendant au niveau des micro-entreprises,
de plus en plus d'entreprises sont en train de réaliser
qu'elles doivent autoriser leurs employés
soit à travailler moins d'heures soit simplement à débrancher --
prendre une pause déjeuner, ou aller s'asseoir dans une salle tranquille,
éteindre leurs Blackberrys -- vous, là, derrière --
téléphones portables,
pendant la journée de travail ou le week-end, pour qu'ils aient le temps de se ressourcer
et pour -- pour que le cerveau glisse vers ce
mode de pensée créatif.
Il n'y a pas que, ceci dit, aujourd'hui,
les adultes qui travaillent trop, quand même, n'est-ce pas ? Il y a aussi les enfants.
J'ai 37 ans, mon enfance s’est terminée à la moitié des années 80,
et je regarde les enfants maintenant, et je suis impressionné par leur façon de
courir partout avec plus de devoirs,
plus de cours, plus de parascolaire,
que nous n'aurions pu en concevoir il y une génération.
Et certains des emails les plus déchirants
que je reçois sur mon site web
viennent en fait d'adolescents
planant au bord du burnout, et m'implorant
d'écrire à leurs parents,
pour les aider à ralentir, pour les aider à descendre de ce
tapis roulant à pleine vitesse.
Mais heureusement, il y a un retournement chez les parents aussi,
et vous trouverez que, vous savez, des villes aux États-Unis d'Amérique
sont maintenant en train de se réunir et de bannir les activités parascolaires
pour un jour précis du mois, pour que les gens puissent,
vous savez, décompresser et avoir un peu de temps en famille, et ralentir.
Les devoirs à la maison sont une autre chose. Il y des interdictions de devoirs
qui apparaissent partout dans les pays développés
dans des écoles qui ont amoncelé les devoirs depuis des années,
et maintenant ils sont en train de découvrir que moins peut être plus.
Donc il y eu un cas en Ecosse récemment
où une école privée payante, performante,
a interdit les devoirs à la maison
pour tous les moins de 13 ans,
et les parents performants ont paniqué et ont dit,
"Qui êtes-vous -- enfin, nos enfants vont baisser de niveau" -- le proviseur a dit,
"Non, non, vos enfants ont besoin de ralentir à la fin de la journée."
Et justement ce dernier mois, les résultats des examens sont arrivés,
et en math, et science, les points sont montés de 20 pour cent
par rapport à la moyenne de l'an passé.
Et je pense que ce qui est très révélateur c'est que
les universités d'élite, qui sont souvent citées comme la raison
pour laquelle les gens poussent leurs enfants et leur font un gavage éducatif,
sont en train de se rendre compte que la qualité des étudiants
qu'ils accueillent se dégrade. Ces enfants ont des notes magnifiques,
ils ont des CVs remplis d'activités parascolaires,
à un point qui vous ferait pleurer.
Mais il leur manque l'étincelle, il leur manque
la capacité de penser de manière créative et penser en-dehors des sentiers battus --
ils ne savent pas comment rêver. Et donc ces universités d'élite,
la bande d'Oxford, Cambridge etc., commencent à envoyer comme message
aux parents et aux étudiants qu'ils ont besoin de freiner un petit peu.
Et à Harvard, par exemple, ils envoient
une lettre aux étudiants de premier cycle -- les petits nouveaux --
en leur disant qu'ils obtiendront plus de la vie, et plus d'Harvard,
s’ils ralentissent. S’ils en font moins,
mais donnent du temps aux choses, le temps que les choses nécessitent,
pour les apprécier, pour les savourer.
Et même si parfois ils ne font rien du tout.
Et cette lettre est appelée -- très révélateur, je pense --
"Ralentissez !" -- avec un point d'exclamation à la fin.
Donc peu importe où vous regardez, le message, il me semble, est le même.
Que moins est très souvent plus,
que plus lentement et très souvent
mieux. Mais cela dit, bien entendu,
ce n'est pas si facile de ralentir, n'est-ce pas ?
Je veux dire, vous avez entendu que j'ai eu une amende pour excès de vitesse
quand je faisais des recherches pour mon livre sur les bienfaits de la lenteur,
et c'est vrai, mais ce n'est pas toute l'histoire.
J'était en fait en route pour un dîner
organisé par Slow Food à l'époque.
Et si comme ce n'était pas assez humiliant comme ça, j'ai eu l'amende en Italie.
Et si quelqu'un parmi vous a déjà roulé sur une autoroute italienne,
il aura une assez bonne idée de la vitesse à laquelle j'allais.
(Rires)
Mais pourquoi est-ce que c'est si dur de ralentir?
Je pense qu'il y a plusieurs raisons.
L'une d'elles est que -- que la vitesse est amusante -- vous savez, la vitesse c'est sexy.
C'est toute cette montée d'adrénaline. C'est dur d'y renoncer.
Je pense qu'il y a un genre de dimension métaphysique --
la vitesse devient une façon de dresser des murailles pour nous isoler
des questions plus grandes, et plus profondes.
On remplit notre tête avec des distractions, avec nos occupations,
pour ne pas avoir à se demander,
est-ce que je vais bien? Est-ce que je suis heureux? Est-ce que mes enfants grandissent bien?
Est-ce que les politiciens prennent de bonnes décisions en mon nom?
Une autre raison -- quoique je pense, peut-être, la raison la plus forte --
pour laquelle nous trouvons que c'est dur de ralentir, c'est le tabou culturel
que nous avons érigé contre le fait de ralentir.
Lent est un gros mot dans notre culture.
C'est un synonyme de paresseux, flemmard,
de quelqu'un qui abandonne.
Vous savez, "il est un peu lent." C'est en fait un synonyme
de -- de stupide.
Je pense que ce que le Mouvement Lent -- le but du Mouvement Lent,
ou son but principal, vraiment, c'est de s'attaquer à ce tabou,
et de dire que -- que oui,
parfois la lenteur n'est pas la -- la réponse,
qu'il y a bien une "mauvaise lenteur."
Vous savez que -- je reste coincé dans la M25,
qui est une route circulaire autour de Londres, récemment,
et j'ai passé 3h et demie dedans. Et je peux vous dire,
que c'est vraiment de la mauvaise lenteur.
Mais l'idée nouvelle,
l'espèce d'idée révolutionnaire du Mouvement Lent,
c'est qu'il existe bien, aussi, une "bonne lenteur".
Et la bonne lenteur est, vous savez, prendre le temps
de manger un repas avec votre famille, la télé éteinte.
Ou -- prendre le temps de regarder un problème sous tous les angles
au bureau pour prendre la meilleure décision
au travail.
Ou même de juste simplement prendre le temps
de ralentir
et de savourer votre vie.
Maintenant, une des choses que j'ai trouvé la plus réjouissante
à propos de tous ces trucs qui sont arrivés autour du livre
depuis qu'il est sorti, c'est la réaction qu'il a suscitée.
Et je savais que lorsque mon livre sur la lenteur sortirait,
il serait accueilli par la brigade New Age,
mais il a aussi été accepté, avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme,
par le monde de l'entreprise -- vous savez, par exemple,
la presse des affaires, mais aussi, vous savez,
les grandes entreprises et les organisations dirigeantes.
Car les gens en haut de la chaîne, les gens comme vous, je pense,
commencent à réaliser qu'il y a trop
de rapidité dans le système,
il y a trop d'occupation, et il est temps de trouver,
ou de revenir à, l'art perdu du changement de vitesse.
Un autre signe encourageant, je pense,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas que dans le monde développé
qu'on accepte cette idée. Dans le monde en voie de développement,
dans les pays qui sont tout près de faire le saut
jusqu'à la première position mondiale -- la Chine, le Brésil,
la Thaïlande, la Pologne, et ainsi de suite --
ces pays sont -- ont adopté l'idée du Mouvement Lent,
beaucoup de gens dans ces pays, et il y a un débat qui se tient
dans leurs media, dans les rues.
Car je pense qu'ils regardent l'Ouest, et ils disent,
"Bon, nous aimons cet aspect de ce que nous avons,
mais nous ne sommes pas sûrs au sujet de ça."
Donc quand on a dit tout ça, est-ce que,
je pense, est-ce que c'est possible?
Ceci est vraiment la question principale qui se présente à nous aujourd'hui. Est-il possible
de ralentir? Et je --
je suis heureux d'être en mesure de vous dire
que la réponse est un fracassant oui.
Et je me présente comme pièce à conviction A,
un genre d'accro à la vitesse
réformé et réhabilité.
J'aime toujours la vitesse. Vous savez j'habite à Londres,
et je travaille comme journaliste,
et j'apprécie le bourdonnement et l'occupation,
et la montée d'adrénaline que ces deux choses apportent.
Je joue au squash et au hockey sur glace,
deux sports très rapides, et je ne les abandonnerais pour rien au monde.
Mais je suis aussi, au cours de cette dernière année,
entré en contact avec ma tortue intérieure.
(Rires)
Et ce que ça veut dire c'est que
je ne -- je ne me
surcharge plus de travail inutilement.
Mon état par défaut n'est plus
d'être un accro à la course.
Je n'entends plus
le char ailé du temps se rapprocher,
ou du moins plus autant qu'avant.
Je l'entends en fait, maintenant, car je vois mon temps s'écouler.
Et le résultat de tout ça c'est que
en fait je me sens beaucoup plus heureux, en meilleure santé,
plus productif, que je ne l'ai jamais été.
Je sens que je -- je vis
ma vie plutôt que, finalement, juste la traverser en courant.
Et peut-être, la plus importante
mesure du succès de tout ça
c'est que je sens que mes relations sont bien plus profondes,
plus riches, et plus fortes.
Et pour moi, le -- je pense, le test pH
pour savoir si cela fonctionnerait, et ce que ça voudrait dire,
serait toujours les histoires du soir, car d'une certaine façon c'est là que le --
le voyage a commencé. Et là aussi les nouvelles sont
roses. Je -- vous savez,
à la fin de la journée, je vais dans la chambre de mon fils.
je ne porte pas de montre. J'éteins mon ordinateur,
pour ne pas entendre le son des emails qui arrivent dans la boite,
et je ralentis exactement à son rythme à lui et -- et nous lisons.
Et parce que les enfants ont leur propre rythme et leur horloge interne,
ils ne fonctionnent pas avec du temps de qualité,
où vous leur prévoyez 10 minutes, pour s'ouvrir à vous.
Ils ont besoin que vous bougiez à leur rythme.
Je découvre qu'après 10 minutes dans une histoire, vous savez,
mon fils va dire tout à coup, "Tu sais,
quelque chose s'est passé dans la cour aujourd'hui qui m'a vraiment embêté."
Et nous allons démarrer une conversation là-dessus.
Et je trouve maintenant que les histoires du soir
étaient un genre de --
une case dans ma liste de choses à faire, quelque chose que je redoutais,
parce que c'était tellement lent et je devais le finir rapidement.
C'est devenu ma récompense à la fin de la journée,
quelque chose que vraiment -- que je chéris vraiment.
Et j'ai un sorte de fin hollywoodienne
à mon discours cet après-midi,
qui donne à peu près ça.
Il y a quelques mois, je me préparais à partir sur
une autre tournée pour mon livre, et j'avais toutes mes valises prêtes.
J'étais en bas à côté de la porte d'entrée, et j'attendais un taxi,
et mon fils est descendu et il avait --
il m'avait fait une carte. Et il l'avait dans la main.
Il était allé agrafer deux cartes, très semblables à celles-ci, ensemble,
et avait mis un autocollant de son
personnage préféré, Tintin, au recto.
Et il m'a dit,
ou plutôt il m'a tendu ça, et -- et il l'a lue,
et ça disait, "A Papa, bisous Benjamin."
Et j'ai pensé, "Aah, c'est vraiment mignon, tu sais,
est-ce que c'est une carte de bonne chance pour la tournée du livre?"
Et il a dit, "Non, non, non, Papa -- c'est une carte
du meilleur liseur d'histoire du monde."
Et j'ai pensé, "Ouais, vous savez, ce truc de ralentir..."
Merci beaucoup.